OJ was a big part of my life yeah there
was a sketch called just say no Jay it
was released on Comedy Central it was
one of these sketches that they would
put between shows and I played a kid
who's playing with the DNA testing kit
at comedy Central's marketing campaign
was just say no Jay stop watching the
trial start watching uh what we're doing
start watching uh reruns of Saturday
Night Live yeah and Mystery Science
Theater and whatever right and premium
blend do we have this let's watch just
saying I would love to Let's watch this
so this is you as a child this is the
first time this has been played on my
podcast I think
[Laughter]
crushed it I've been in this business
for years Trevor
OJ one of your first paying jobs it
wouldn't happen without him one of my
first paying gigs so like I'm in the
business
because of the juice